a two and four start I'm really looking
forward to that suer game I mean I
obviously can we talk about I say I
really like Milwaukee to win that game
actually pretty easy pretty easy pretty
easy yeah I mean they just better than
the Knicks but that game too man I'm
concerned about my sons I am because of
all the
injuries uh you know and if you go back
and look because obviously I live in
Phoenix that we're talking I this yo man
these guys they all three I missed a lot
of games the last three three or four
years it ain't just this year and you
got to wonder of what position they're
going to be cuz you know Bradley bills
is not even close to plan and um we'll
have Booker and Durant tomorrow it did
but that like that that that won't be
enough I don't think they can beat the
Lakers tomorrow Lakers have won both
meetings so far both of those um one by
one by five and one by three they've
played at both places I like Milwaukee
Yiannis has won a championship obviously
Dame talks about winning a championship
and they must know and understand say
beat the teams you're supposed to beat
supposed to beat the Knicks every time
you said they're playing well against
the Knicks they're supposed to so they
need to get used to that that that
format and understand that and become
real consistent at staying down there at
home beating the teams you're supposed
to beat and staying way above 500 on the
rad nine and one at home and they've won
eight in a row in their gym and how
about the Lakers and Suns I might have
to go with the
Lakers you know I'm not really impressed
with the Suns yet they have a lot of
talent I know uh bill has has been in
and out but you know the Lakers are
playing well you know ad we we jump on
him a lot but when he's playing
consistent when he's playing like the ad
especially the ad we saw it when he was
playing for the Pelicans if he's close
to that and the others are stepping up
and they're playing with that great
energy I like the Lakers I'm not sold on
Phoenix yet you know Phoenix does have a
better Phoenix is 12 and8 Lakers are 12
and N 1 eight out of 10 but I'm saying
seven and three on the road second best
record in the NBA yeah but I think if
you're the Lakers you got to be
concerned because you're asking an awful
lot of a 38 going to be 39 year old guy
and a couple weeks you know at this
stage of LeBron's career as great as
he's been that's a lot this early in the
season so you have concern for both
teams uh well I because you were
concerned about the sun I'm concerned
about the injuries with the sun because
they're so topheavy with those three
guys but they missed so much time but
the thing with the Lakers LeBron you
know they started out the season like
we're only going to play you 30 32
minutes T night but those 32 now they up
to 35 but they're not an easy 35 he's
still the best player on their on their
team and for a guy 38 going on 39 in a
couple of weeks you got to say to
yourself man we've only played 20 games
basically and we got a long way to go
yeah I I understand I think that that's
a
fair thought process assess
however when you're coaching a game or
you're playing a game you're not saying
oh the guy's 39 you're just watching him
perform and you're like he's he's being
productive so it leaves your mindset it
leaves LeBron's and so you have to play
him until it doesn't work you I just
think you have to play him until it
doesn't it starts not to
work